[Music]
this has been one of my favorite anime
of the year and as someone who gets off
talking about deep characters and
complex storylines i have to admit i'm a
bit ashamed about that that time i got
reincarnated as a slime has so many
things that should irritate me starting
with that stupid fitting title the main
character effortlessly gets more and
more powers with practically no stakes
there is a sea of side characters
introduced that i can't and won't care
all about and there is no clear
overarching narrative that seems to tie
the story together being a bit of a
gourmet when it comes to the exquisite
writing and stories like one piece due
to kaisen or hanza hunter i feel like i
should be loathing this piece of feel
good escapist isekai and yet i goddamn
love it i loved the first season and
what's even worse i love the second
season even more
though whether you love or hate him or
actually haven't seen the anime at all
let me tell you why i think that rimo
tempesto is such a fantastic character
why you should definitely watch the
anime and why this little blue slime
here makes such a fantastic story for me
now if you're not living in japan it'll
probably not be so easy for you to just
get any manga you like whenever you want
or can you i have partnered up with
bookwalker an online bookstore and app
for reading manga and light novels
digitally worldwide they have a
ridiculously awesome selection of manga
and light novels for you to explore of
course that time i got reincarnated as a
slime is part of the selection and right
now with the end of the second season
they have a special offer for you with
up to 30 of the manga including the
entire set coinback and even some bonus
items until the 18th of october also if
you use my code o'hara you can get 600
yens or about 5 bucks of your first
purchase link is in the description
below so once you've watched this video
make sure to check it out by the way if
you want this copy of the manga all you
have to do is subscribe as you already
should be and i'll pick one random
comment to send this to now there are
two things that make this anime so great
to me the setup of the story as well as
its main character
tempesto
now the big strength of the story to me
is that it doesn't try to be clever or
pretends to be anything it is not it
doesn't try to preach any deep messages
nor does it forcibly avert expectations
and tropes just for the sake of it
looking at you game of thrones well
danny kind of forgot about the iron
fleet it doesn't go out of its way to be
creative but it simply follows the rules
of good writing characters are developed
the world is built and everything that
happens gets clean set up and
foreshadowing
[Music]
the story doesn't try to break the rules
but simply follows them with a lot of
discipline in other words this anime
knows what it is and what it is not and
absurdly enough i think it's exactly
this authenticity alone that makes it
already stand out the premise is as
simple as the title suggests a young man
dies in our normal world and is reborn
as a slime in another world only of
course that he gets ridiculous powers
right from the get-go
classic isekai escapism from there on
out we basically follow our slime hero
who shares our modern 21st century
perspective as he discovers this new
world gets stronger and stronger and
starts building a small nation of
monsters like maybe it's just me but
that premise just hits a nerf with me
i've always loved strategic development
games like age of empires harvest moon
or hell even minecraft
yes getting stronger is part of the fun
but the real struggle is in building
something big so as a kid or even today
sometimes i like to daydream about what
it would be like to be put into one of
your favorite stories with the best set
of powers and how you could build your
own small comfortable place with it does
that make any sense i think that fuse
the author of slime i'm just going to
call it slime from now on i mean come on
i think that's exactly what fuse did
when he created the
[Applause]
is story a shounen hero who has to get
stronger or even a hero like saitama who
needs to grow on the inside instead he
was already a pretty decent person and
leader even back as a human as we see in
the first episode his junior seems to
like and respect him and while his
character does have a dark side to it
sometimes
[Music]
i honestly think that this is nothing
that has to be changed limunu's
character arc is not about growing from
a boy to a man or from a man into a
leader it's about growing from a leader
into a visionary that can change or form
a whole society so it's not really about
him getting stronger or dealing with his
emotions that we want to see even though
these things do happen but to me it's
much more about the rimuru growing to be
a leader not of a small team in his
company but that of a whole nation
learning about diplomacy and
infrastructure and the politics of this
world with the necessary power to back
it up
[Music]
that's what the story is about and why
it is so much fun to watch and it really
doesn't pretend to be anything more than
that a major factor in this context at
least to me is the fact that irimuru is
a grown man that also acts like a grown
man most of the time he is a bit naive
but a quick learner and most importantly
he is emotionally mature something that
is so
incredibly refreshing for a main
character and anime because it gives the
entire story a certain maturity as well
when it comes to his actions decisions
and relationships with the other
characters
[Music]
even the fan service in the story while
undoubtedly there holy calcium how can
you walk with these is definitely not as
over the top as i thought in the
beginning plus it's surprisingly
balanced between male and female
characters let's just make everyone sexy
the main themes that i think are pretty
easy to pick out right away include
racial inequality helping others
individual growth positive civilization
growth choosing one's battles as well as
being compassionate but still rational
and let's be honest these are all
incredibly feel-good themes but even
though i usually prefer darker stories
it
works for me because the anime
compromises this with some quite graphic
imaging but more importantly a shift in
focus between the two seasons
season one and two of slime felt very
very coherent when i first watched them
but now that the season is over i am
disgusted to say that this is actually
one of the rare cases where our season 2
actually made the season one
better feels weird saying that season 1
is all about getting familiar with our
main character a ton of world building
and the establishment of the nation in
europe forest and while this was a lot
of fun to watch to me there were some
pretty big problems on the horizon
should the story have simply continued
on like this i mean in season 1 there
are literally no stakes and no personal
challenges for the muru also the focus
on our slime made it absolutely
impossible to care for most if any of
the many many characters thrown in with
every single episode at the end the
village just feels like one faceless
blob to me season 2 however right off
the bat i feel did a fantastic job
addressing all these potential pitfalls
limuru losing shion and many of his
other friends not only gives him his
first taste of reality and hardship but
it also provides some serious character
development as well that pushes the
narrative forward for instance he now
has to deal with the fact that the three
rules of civilization that he came up
with on the fly in season 1 were hasty
and unsustainable in the face of all the
ill intent coming towards his new nation
[Music]
overall the story and world of slime
takes on a darker shade which
immediately satisfies people like me who
like some more complexity just because
rimoto is strong doesn't mean he can
protect everyone all the time and so he
has to start handing off more and more
responsibility to more and more of his
followers this immediately solves the
other big issue with season 1. instead
of endlessly adding more no-name
characters to the village we get
characterization for all those from
season 1 which ultimately has left me
with a much better connection to
characters like benimaru gopta or xion
than in the first season all of these
characters are now not only super
powerful themselves but also act
independently from the modu which is
really refreshing to see and all the
characters that do get added all have
fantastic
or at least interesting personalities
diabolo and my boy veldra are all very
easy to relate to even though we got
very little of them in season one and by
the way i can't believe that they had
veldra do a kamehameha
[Music]
so despite a very simple and textbook
setup the story executes the rules of
good storytelling so well that it's
impossible for me not to like it and be
super excited to see what comes next for
the modu and his friends i hope you want
to watch a little bit more now so if you
want you can watch this video here next
thanks for watching and as someone who
comes